first you lived it then you wrote a book
about it and now there's this film how
as you watch it does it look to you the
story that's told here you know when we
wrote son of Hamas book I did not write
the book I'm not a writer I told the
story to a writer and he wrote the book
I thought I would change the Middle East
and I think I was wrong then I learned
the lesson that the book is not me and
this documentary basically is not me
it's not me it's my persona it's part of
me I'm not limited to this it's just a
production you cannot encapsulate a
human experience in any form in my
opinion I think the work is is amazing
it represented the story and it was a
very difficult job thankfully for Nadav
and the rest of the team who could put
things together I personally try to stay
unattached you can say that this is not
my reality anymore and I look at it with
Grace and I try to be as easy as I can I
think that a book and a film can change
but if we expect the change to be
immediate it's not going to be immediate
I think that if we give our people in
the in the West Bank in Israel the
opportunity to think about what they see
criticize what they see we didn't try to
be heroes in the movie it's not a movie
about heroism it's movie about choices
about our mistakes and I think that if
we give them the opportunity to think
about it and to criticize in the long
run it can bring a change but of course
it's not going to be a very fast date
change we made sure or we tried our best
to keep the politics out of the story
for us
the filmmakers after bad it is a very
human story
and to story about two people of our
friends here so you know the politics
were in the background and it's
inescapable but but for us the story is
a story about a relationship primarily
one very interesting thing that happened
in the process of editing is that we
originally had interviewed a wide array
of characters to give context or the
former head of the Shin Bet was a was
very much involved in the operations
back then was was a character that we
interview we had other special agents
and people who give context and as we
were editing we realized that they were
not part of the story in that the story
ultimately was just about the
relationship between Musab and Gonen and
so whatever was extraneous to this
relationship we we took out and if if
you watch the film again you can see
that the narrative arc in effect is the
narrative arc of a relationship so that
became the artistic challenge and and to
create a you know drama the events in
our friends story of highly dramatic but
then to create a distiller of it was
just two characters to have the audience
gripped from moment one until the end
was two characters that became the
artistic channel what for you was the
tipping point that made you say I know
what's right and this isn't right and
therefore I'm going to work with people
like Conan I found myself like this
moment at intersection and I made a
choice and most of the time when I make
the choice I think about my higher
conscience even though at that point in
the past it calibrated in a falsehood
when I was seeking revenge but at some
point I transcended my own conscience
and again this is a story of growth and
it's an evolution I served basically my
conscience I did not serve a political
party or a government or a religion and
at some point I had to choose between
family identity culture comfort zone or
stand for my truth which you know
sometimes very hard now the moments when
I served my selfish desires which you
know happens from now and then
I always hit a dead end I hit a wall
so I shoes you know to keep on growing
consciously and keep transcending even
though sometimes I have to read to hit
the road towards the unknown you know
many times we we need to make decisions
and our decisions are being made by the
influence of our friends or our family
this the society the where we live and
we don't follow our heart here I needed
to follow my heart in those events and I
knew that you know the outcome of what
I'm going to do is going to be either
dangerous for me from from my point of
view legally it could be dangerous I can
tell you that some of my friends didn't
like what I what I did have friends in
in the agency they didn't like what what
I do they you know they told me we don't
understand your motive you know what
what are you trying to do no leave it go
to the side and that time I needed to
follow my heart and I think that you
know people should go back and remember
you know that we have intuition
sometimes we need to go with it for me
it was difficult because I was already
tired of telling my story honestly you
know the son of Hamas book was very
successful by all the standards it got
to the New York Times top ten best
seller list and it became international
bestseller and all the translations but
for me that was not enough because this
is not what I was trying to do you know
to get on your Times bestseller list or
become famous or whatever it is
because it came on a very high cost you
know my parents don't talk to me today
because of this attempt it was suicidal
basically and when I decided to go
suicidal I was expecting to have to make
a change to make a difference to see
people like bigger debate the first
thing I started in the wall of the
American media misunderstanding you know
the messages and motives behind the
project which you know put me always at
defense speaking engagements you know
people would question my integrity
rather than you know look at the core of
the story and understand what I'm trying
to deliver to them so by the time when
the death came to the production I was
in the jungle somewhere and I had to
come back for that it was not an easy
thing what attracts me to this I guess
it's you know the the power of real-life
stories I mean a Hollywood screenwriter
could not have dreamt this story you
know it's it's much greater than fiction
as corny as it sounds and it's for me
much more inspiring than fiction you
know III had goosebumps when I met going
in into the babe and I understood the
nature of their relationship I was
covered with goose bumps because it made
many things possible